[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar delivering improved
bioprocessing workflows the
manufacturing and science technology
nsat service i'm borga cults product
manager
for services and i'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots
and brought to you by fujifilm irvine
scientific
to learn more visit irvinesci.com
we do encourage you to participate today
by submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like now to welcome our speakers tom
fletcher director of process development
r d at fujifilm irvine scientific
and michael de la cruz phd senior
scientist at fujifilm irvine scientific
tom and mike you may now begin your
presentation
yeah thank you so much parker for the
introduction so it's my pleasure today
to tell you about this new service we're
very excited about
so
fujifilm as you may know has made some
strategic investments in life sciences
and
many of these investments have to do
with cell biology and so here's kind of
a chart of you know various companies
that have been acquired by
fujifilm strategically
and so fujifilm irvine scientific is one
of those companies and
what ties a lot of these companies
together also is the need for cell
culture media so that's kind of our
specialty and so we're very happy to be
part of this
family of life science companies
it's not only you know good for our
business but honestly we've we've
learned so much since uh in just a few
years we've been part of this family
because now we have a rich
variety of
collaborators and uh so it's really
strengthened our knowledge base
so we've been in the cell culture media
business for 50 years
but
we're still learning and it's been
really a great experience for us to work
with some of these companies that you
you may recognize everyone from fujifilm
diasynth which is a cd moan to fujifilm
waka which is a chemical supplier
so this is kind of background for who we
are and
why it's such a dynamic time at our
company
so you may know also that we have a
reputation over our many years of
developing products that have been
designed
for the purpose of use and so it's this
design principle again you may be
familiar with is very common
begin with the end in mind so this is
how we approach new product development
and so i've listed here in the bullet
point some of the characteristics that
go along with
products that have been designed with
the end in mind so what we call
purpose-built products
and so this has been you know our
practice again over many years but
recently we realized that um you know
since we have a large business also in
manufacturing
media that belong to our customers where
the formula belongs to our customers
we realized it was fairly obvious that
maybe we should begin offering these
advantages
to our customers you know who own their
own formula so not just our own products
but you know since we've got this
experience and it's quite valuable why
don't we extend you know that know-how
and that capability
to help our customers
um improve their processes so you know
for the most part this relates to
practical issues you know i talk about
being soluble
being filterable being stable
and then i put a star next to this one
bullet point that says no ph osmolality
or volume adjustments required
so again we we know how to do that we've
been doing it over many years as you
know we sell both liquid and powder and
we've learned how to make those you know
basically equivalent and also so that
the powder can just
be added to water quickly dissolved and
used so
this is sort of you know in a nutshell
what the msat service is all about you
know we just asked that obvious question
how can we take these advantages that we
know how to achieve
and
offer those to
our customers who own their own formulas
and
so
you know again let me just expand a
little bit so that
you understand how relevant this is you
probably recognize some of these issues
on the slide here so there are very
common
issues that we find um you know
throughout the industry with
powder media in particular and so there
are some of the issues in the first
group i would say
you could describe as chemical issues so
it has to do with how to hydrate the
powder
you know whether it's solubility
interactions between the components so
kind of technical issues related to
chemistry
the second group of bullet points here
are more about practical issues
related to the amount of labor the
amount of
handling
decision making human intervention
and of course this is where a lot of the
variation a lot of the opportunities for
errors
occur when the technician is required to
you know do something very very
carefully
and so these are two categories we
believe we can address both of them
again based on experience so
this is again kind of a general
description at a high level with the
msat service is about we'll have a k uh
you know some case studies here coming
near the end of the presentation
but again from a high level we had you
know quite a bit of experience
offering services so we don't just sell
products and we don't just manufacture
custom media
we actually have a range of services
those services until now have been
focused really on early stage projects
where people are developing media we
have ways to help them develop those
media more rapidly more efficiently
but as you know what happens during drug
development
is as a candidate moves through clinical
trials
the the needs and the interests change
so as a project moves into late stages
it's not as much about speed anymore as
it is about reliability and cost
and so realizing that the needs are
changing and being actually requested to
help um as a full service media partner
you know our customers will call us
first when there's an issue anything
related to media so more and more we
were noticing
that the the needs were changing we were
noticing that we didn't always have you
know the right service to meet the need
and so again it just it came somewhat
organically through interacting with our
customers that we realized what we need
to do is to begin offering
this type of a more
a service that would help with a more
mature project in late stages help them
with practical issues of how to prepare
the media at large scale
how to do it with less variation less
errors
and how to do it in a more cost
effective
manner so again if you go all the way to
the right i list some examples of where
this provides benefits where we can
improve solubility we can troubleshoot
you know their their bill of materials
we can help simplify
their process
and we can even apply automation so
that's something i'll just mention
briefly but
we know how to prepare media we do it
every single day
and so um through that experience we're
able to offer i believe a valuable
service to help to help our customers
and
so
again just to help bring this to reality
for those of you who who uh
are involved in large scale media prep
here's some very um specific examples
just a list but it ends up being a long
list it's not so much these particular
examples as how long the list is of
different things that people need so
again as a full service media partner we
hear a lot about
issues like this and so we can certainly
improve somebody's process simply by
delivering ready to use uh packaging you
know pre-measured quantities
we can we know how to design the powder
media so that the adjustments won't be
required
there's so much time and variation being
introduced by having somebody make
adjustments
we know how to integrate nutrients into
a single bulk powder instead of adding
you know each one individually
and at the same time we know how to keep
the um those components that might cause
trouble because they interact we can
separate them
and again i won't read the whole list
but you get the idea that just from
experience and through um
just you know understanding what the
risks are we're able to
overcome some of these very common
challenges
and obviously it's rooted in fundamental
chemistry so i'm just going to pick on
one component here it's got a reputation
and that is the tyrosine so tyrosine
causes a lot of issues in cell culture
media
in feed media
and so it's you know once you understand
the chemistry of tyrosine i think it
helps you understand why there's not
only so much issue with it but
how there are opportunities to overcome
those issues so for example if we simply
will use a high ph for dissolving
tyrosine
we'll probably be able to achieve a much
higher solubility
and a better stability also of this
this amino acid so it's it's unique in
several ways
uh compared to other amino acids
and so that explains i think why it's
also unique in terms of you know the
amount of challenges it presents to us
so just looking at some diagrams here of
how the ph influences the structure and
the behavior of tyrosine
again we can look at this and realize oh
well that helps us understand how to
deal with
those practical challenges with tyrosine
so we might introduce it as a separate
stock solution at high concentrations
um and and again it's all based in
fundamental chemistry it's not that
we're inventing
you know any novel chemistry or
proprietary chemistry is that we're
taking knowledge that's available to us
and applying it to the benefit of our
customer
so
you know similar to
tyrosine we can recognize individual
nutrients and their
behavior
for example here i'm just showing the
effect of sodium chloride so
the ionic strength of the solution
affects solubility in the case of
cysteine you know we have kind of a
salting in effect tyrosine and leucine
just the opposite so just knowing these
things having a knowledge base that's
available to us
to design media to help solve problems
i think is really where the benefit
comes from
and then
you know by combining these effects we
realize it quickly becomes complex and
so i'm just showing you here very
briefly how you know looking at two
amino acids at a time
is also interesting and thanks to
not only our own work but some of the
work we've done in collaboration with
with groups like ambik for example we're
able to understand and
and apply
what's been learned across the industry
in terms of how amino acids affect each
other so quickly on the chart at the
right i'm showing how
with alanine there are some amino acids
that improve the solubility and other
amino acids that actually have
a a negative effect
so
these amino acids will impact each other
in terms of the combined solubility of
the of the amino acids
and then just very quickly just before
we get into case studies i just want to
tell you there's a bright future in this
area also which keeps us you know
motivated and excited we're excited to
be part of the ambit consortium where
we're working with
many other companies in the industry
and uh part of that effort that we're
excited about is developing in silico
models where we'll be able to make
predictions about how to combine
different nutrients how to group the
nutrients in ways that are most cost
effective and most reliable
and so that's something we're quite
excited about
it will really save time and i think
result in more reliable media design
in the second case um we're also very
excited about a new automated approach
to media development and i wish i could
tell you more about it right here but um
we'll certainly be talking about this
more in the future
we've designed a system that's able to
um you know based on the same chemistry
able to achieve
rapid and reliable automated media and
buffer prep
so that's the end of my section uh
apologize if i went very fast there but
i'd like to hand it over to
mike dela cruz for some description of
actual case studies
thank you tom for the great overview of
the service i hope that everyone can see
that the incest service addresses the
existing lack of support for the media
preparation unit operation at the late
stage of bioproduction
next i'll present a case study
of an opportunity we recently worked on
as you will see it gives a good
representation of what the service is
all about
and what solutions it can provide to
your manufacturing workflow
our main goal is to improve the media
preparation method
by simplifying the complicated
multi-component multi-powder liquid
preparation
into easy to use powders that are easy
to hydrate and scalable all the way up
to gmp manufacturing
as you will see in this case we started
with three powders and a very
complicated meta preparation method
that typically took four hours to make
and we ended with a simple one-hour
hydration process
the real value comes
from the mitigation of risk where later
you will avoid any viability introduced
in the process
and you can follow a lean manufacturing
methodology which is so important now
with multi-product facilities ensuring
there is no disruption to the supply
chain due to any issues with the media
at the end it is all about optimizing
the efficiency of your ds manufacturing
facility
in this case study we were approached by
a previous customer
who had used a couple of our products
including two fujifilm's media server
panels a growth and a feed media panel
this customer has developed a production
media for a drug substance antibody
process that could potentially use more
than 100 kilograms per liter of media
per year
if they knew that
the preparation method was not
manufacturing friendly since it was
typically taking up to four hours to
prepare the medium each time even at
small at small scale
so this was going to be a real challenge
at large scale
one of the main reasons for the issues
encounter was that they had co-developed
a supplement powder with a cdmo which
did not fully hydrate as a complete
powder when it was first ordered from
our express media service
but because our customers previous
experience with this powder they
understood that it will be fully
solubilized
when the ph was adjusted up to 9.5
and it would stay in solution when
it was adjusted back to neutral ph
therefore the limit of solubility of the
powder components had not been reached
the basic strategy that the msa servers
follow for this particular customer can
be divided into four basis basic tasks
of redesigning the formula and method
which are depicted here in this circular
diagram starting at the top left we were
first
where we first compiled and tabulated
the customer's formula information
this allows us to compare the formula to
both internal and other commercial media
to look for any potential challenges due
to solubility limits or undesirable
interactions between the components
then in the next three steps we turn our
attention to the method where we
eliminated the complicated adjustments
we can which can be avoided
we eliminated the ph adjustments by
balancing some of the weak acids
with the conjugated bases in order to
meet the ph set points
at this point we also had to be mindful
that not all components will be added in
the main powder therefore the impact to
the ph of these additions had to be a
better understood which could only be
done empirically
and to really simplify the preparation
the usual hard to dissolve components
were prepared as a high ph concentrated
liquid supplement
this supplement is added during the
preparation and completely and
eliminates the need for ph titration at
the point of use
we eliminated the need for any
osmolarity adjustments
and because the amount of titrants used
to solubilize the hard to dissolve
compounds was minimized
we were able to eliminate the issues of
which highest molarity that the customer
was having with the old method that made
it a challenge
to meet the final specifications of the
liquid media
additionally
we eliminated the need for adjusting
the volume at the end since we can
accurately determine how much water to
start with
and as the diagram shows
this was an iterative process where
these four activities were revisited
as the formula and method were fully
redeveloped and optimized
our main goal for this particular case
was to simplify the media preparation
method in order to streamline the
manufacturing process workflow
as i mentioned
the customer had used fujifilm growth
and feed media server panels as well as
a supplement powder not developed by us
to find an optimal production media
formula
yet when combined these powders were
insoluble without a ph manipulation
making the hydration method very
complicated and long
but by using designing and engineering
activities known to resolve these and
similar issues with meta preparation
which included
substituting components with equivalent
nutrient compounds
with higher solubility solubility limits
which include the sodium salts of amino
acids and dipeptides
we also used alternate metacomplexes
that avoided detrimental changes in the
redox state of these components when in
solution
that led to precipitant formation
these and other changes allow us to
combine the majority of the components
into a single powder
and as i mentioned the hard to dissolve
components were provided to the
customers
as the high ph concentrated supplement
solution that decided during preparation
at the point of use
we and the customer understood that
these changes helped increase the
reliability of this unit operation by
eliminating avoidable inter
interventions that introduce viability
and error to their process
this in turn reduces the amount of time
and labor that is allocated to the meter
preparation
the save time and extra
extra time could potentially be used on
other activities that will help increase
the overall efficiency of the facility
and because the preparation method is so
simple
it's guaranteed to easily scale up
and be transferred to any manufacturing
facility
so at the end we were able to provide
our customer with a user-friendly media
and the concentrated supplement solution
to address the solubility issues
encounter and the simplified preparation
method
in this series of pictures you can see
how the media was prepared at small
scale to verify the final formula and
hydrator method before sending it to the
customer
after the addition of the concentrated
liquid supplement the ph shifts from 5
to just about 7
after which the solution will start to
become clear and eventually becoming
completely translucent
the final targeted ph of 7.5 is achieved
after the sodium bicarbonate is added
since we started with the exact volume
of water that is required
no final adjustment to the volume were
made
and finally the medium was filtered and
store cold
so we quickly received positive feedback
from the customer that that the
preparation time had been
reduced down to about an hour
here's the composition of this final
single production medium powder in terms
of percentage of each of the original
powders used
45 percent of the final powder is
represented by the growth medium 20
by the feed medium and 35 is represented
by the supplement powder developed by
the customer
and we were able to provide any of our
customer with highly concentrated high
ph liquid supplements which in this case
represents one percent of the final
volume
and as i said we received positive
feedback from the group who had
previously been preparing the media
and they were really happy
to have a single powder to hydrate and
found that the new simplified
preparation method with minimal
additions and no adjustments
was easy to follow
because this customer use fujifilm's
msa service
they are better prepared to adopt their
recently launched automated media
preparation system the osu rover
since the methodologies used in both the
meter cartridges used in the author
rover and the msa service are based on
the same basic chemistry
and what we like most um to hear most is
that our customers are fully satisfied
with their experience using themselves
service
with with positive feedback like this
these are direct quotes from our
customers after they had tested the
powder and preparation method in their
lab
telling us how
the preparation was now a wonderful
experience since they have been able to
complete a 10 liter preparation and
filtering within one hour
where it would have typically taken them
between three to four hours
the final ph and our similarity set
points were met
and the metabolic measurements were
comparable to previous preparations
and finally the customers confirmed that
the media met the expected cell culture
performance
in take away
we have identified customers gaps
buyside has their resources and
capabilities needed to address these
gaps
and with the msa service offerings we
will be able to meet our customers needs
at the late stage of process development
thank you for listening
thanks for that introduction to the msat
program tom and mike
we wanted to chat some more today about
some of the work we've done since we
started nsat last september and some of
the issues that clients have
come to us with
and one thing we've been asked since we
do have several existing programs like
mdo media development and optimization
and the express media service
why did we also feel that we needed msat
okay right well you know i'd love to
tell you that it was the clever
brainchild you know of a brilliant
businessman but that's that's actually
not the case what what it was so we
noticed you know that we were being
asked
to help on certain types of projects we
noticed that there was
a need and basically we were having uh
customers ask this and so so we did
recognize that it was an unmet need
and that that was really uh the driver
for us to initiate this
this service as i think i mentioned on
one of the slides is more about you know
the practical issues that come later on
in a drug development um
a timeline so it's it's more around uh
you know when the change when the change
in interest comes down to um practical
issues or
cost of goods
and so again we're focused on really
helping to streamline that media prep
that buffer prep
those types of processes
and so you know i mean i can go quickly
through like the ems service that you
mentioned that's about rapidly providing
materials to the customer to support
their development activities
so they don't have to wait for the full
gmp
manufacturing of their media so we can
quickly get those materials to into
their hands you know in uh
you know 10 days or less i think is what
we can do there and then for
spent media analysis that's very
important during media and process
development so we can do things like
that
and then the mdo is like a full service
media development program
so we can we can all do all of those
things they're quite successful
but this was more focused on the later
stages of drug development where um
it's not as much about speed i'm not
saying that we're slow either by the way
but it's more focused on how to save on
time how to reduce labor
how to improve the efficiency of the
process and obviously how to avoid these
risks that we've been talking about with
solubility
stability
what i would categorize as very
practical issues that have to do with
scaling up and creating a robust
process for commercial use
and customers have asked us how those
advantages that
you mentioned earlier of purpose-built
products
how those could apply to their own media
right okay so when i mentioned purpose
builds you know i was talking about our
own uh products that we sell
commercially and so
as we developed those we just learned
about how to make them
easy to use how to avoid you know the
intervention that's often required and
keep in mind of course we're
manufacturing these products not only as
powders but also as liquids
and and one thing that we do that i
think is different than a lot of our uh
competition
we're actually manufacturing the
complete bulk powders
we sell those of course but we use them
also to make the liquids there's no
question about comparability between the
liquid and powder
because of that practice
sometimes you'll hear in the industry
this phrase you know the liquid is made
from from first principles
and i'm not sure where that phrase
originated but it means that people are
making the liquid by adding one nutrient
or one component at a time so that's
something we we almost never do here
it's it's you know we make a complete
bulk powder
then we'll make the liquid and through
that experience of understanding how to
um design the bulk powder
so that there's no um adjustments so
that it's easy to prepare as a liquid
we realized we were on to something that
could benefit our customers as well
and so that's that's kind of where we
took that purpose-built concept we
learned from it
and then as we engage with customers and
learn more about their processes
we were honestly quite surprised to see
how much um
you know amount how much time and effort
was being put into
simple liquid media prep and you know
for us it was fairly obvious we're like
oh well had you ever thought about you
know
pre-engineering your powder so you don't
need your operators to be
so busy making adjustments and it's
really not just about the time and
effort it's about
the variation that can result when
you're relying on your technician to
make these critical adjustments and and
things like that so
again just by doing this for a long time
i would say we've we've kind of learned
that there are smarter ways of doing
this
and decided you know
that that would be valuable to our
customers and so we're excited to bring
that value to our customers it's not
something
we want to keep selfishly and you know
kind of leverage it
uh by trying to persuade people to buy
our off-the-shelf media
we you know
i guess consistently with our um
philosophy of helping our customers
succeed and that's the best way for us
to
generate long-term success
we're out there offering this uh this
you know now know-how you might call it
know-how
to uh help our customers succeed and um
you know we're happy to offer that
experience to the benefit of our
customers
yeah and we have several examples where
we have actually applied some of these
methodologies that have been developed
here over the course of 50 years of
you know of preparing media
in some of these examples um you know we
basically are focusing on you know
looking at the formula and the method
um sometimes we can do both sometimes we
could do just one
so for example in the case that i
presented i might show that we're able
to modify that media
formula because
the
customer was actually able to do so and
willing to do so so in those cases we
like to you know we were able to
incorporate those three powders into one
by exchanging some of the few components
in
substituting them with more soluble
components we were able to improve the
solubility of that media
but we also looked at a method and tried
to simplify as much as possible you know
we eliminated any the ph adjustments
volume adjustments but we have also
worked with some clients that don't have
the flexibility of changing their
formula
they pretty much have it locked down
and what they really want to
have us do is look at some particular
issues they're having with
you know the media so it could be
you know the actual
they want to see whether the actual
method and factors that are involved in
that method are contributing to these
issues that are they're observing there
could be you know stability issues or
issues of cell cultural performance so
for example we work with a client that
was having an issue of stability um
and they they weren't able to meet their
um
the schedules uh because the media
wasn't stable for as long as they needed
to be so we quickly were able to do a
root cause analysis and identify some of
the factors that were
affecting the performance of the media
and you know it was a very simple
solution they didn't have to do much it
was basically changing the way that they
handled the powder and the way that we
package the powder and provide it to
them that allow us to take care of that
that issue very simply by you know
making some simple changes
in that case it was because
the powder was susceptible to moisture
so we knew that um with better handling
of the powder they wouldn't run into
those problems in another case we um
worked it on the client that had some
issues that were
in the cell culture performance and they
want to see whether or not some of these
factors in their media preparation
because they had a very
you know difficult um and complex
method
were involved
ph
adjustments um osmolarity adjustments
and volume adjustments
so we took those
factors
and identify which you know one
of those were actually contributing to
this effect that they were seeing
through by building a doe
and
so we were able to provide them with the
prototypes to run those does which in
this case
we had a four-factor
doe
which allows to
through this uh screening with um 11
prototypes which is in about 23 runs
um with um with a center point as well
so um by doing this methodology we're
actually able to identify
that
some of these factors it was actually a
two-factor interaction that was
seemed to be very significant um when ph
os molarity were interacting
seem to have a definitional effect later
on in the culture not only that but each
of those independent factors were also
significant but we also found out that
for example the volume
adjustment at the end really wasn't
contributing much to that effect so um
in that way you're able to focus on
those
particular factors that you need to
really um have
full control and maybe tightness aspects
of your
method so that you can reliably
make this media without the variability
that they were seeing
so yeah i mean the ultimate goal is to
basically improve
their so
their methods of hydration so that the
zener operation is more reliable and
their efficiency of their facility is
improved yeah and as you give those
examples back it reminds me that you
know a lot of these projects that we've
worked on and we didn't realize this in
the beginning but they kind of come out
of investigations and so i guess another
way of saying it is people don't realize
that they need this kind of a service
until they bump into a problem and say
can you help me you know what do i do
because they're having issues and
problems um
so you know i mean it's always better if
we would have done this ahead of time
hindsight is you know 2020 but what ends
up happening most of these projects are
generated when people do run into
problems and so it becomes it starts as
an investigation and then this service
ends up being you know part of the
solution to those issues
so i'm not saying it has it should
always go that way but that's then most
of the work we've had so far has been
kind of problem solving yeah
well then based on some of the questions
we've gotten from clients maybe it's
important to mention that we can work
both on
some combination of our own uh faisal
media formulations that customers are
using but also
really expensively with clients formulas
too can't we
oh yeah absolutely there's no
restriction there in fact again as we
think through the examples of what we've
been doing so far
i think it's mostly customer owned
formulas um
so there's no obstacle there in terms of
you know ip ownership or the formula um
the you know where we start from
it's really focused on these practical
issues um
and again there's no there's no game
here you know that we're trying to uh
win an iep position or something like
that this is really just us um bringing
our experience to the table
and helping overcome challenges um or
prevent challenges i would rather than
most of the projects were preventing
these kind of challenges but
you know we'll just take we'll take the
opportunities as they come and solve the
problems that we can yeah so we've gone
through several of these already and you
know we already know you know how the
process goes you know
um we we meet with the client at the
beginning and you know we really like to
um spend most of our time in the
planning stage at the beginning of that
stage so that we could you know clearly
identify that issue that they're
encountering so that we could identify
what actual factors are
influencing that effect that they're
seeing and we do this through root cause
analysis and so on and um through the
several iterations of um
of
planning and
experimental um
building we
come up with the actual um experimental
plan
which you know we're part of that in
terms of providing you
with the prototypes and most of the
times
the client is doing the screening
on site and um
it really depends um you know
on the client's capabilities of how big
or you know how they would like to
conduct those experiments so all of that
is worked out through all this process
of planning
and um and then executing the experiment
and site
and once they um
have um come up with all the data
they provide that to us and we analyze
it for them and we then are able to
provide those um
easy
to use solutions and to improve their
methodologies their
hydrogen processes
since we began offering the msat service
last september we had the privilege of
helping customers resolve numerous cases
of
preparation issues
that attendees here might find
interesting too could you tell us a
little bit more about those challenges
yeah sure i mean i guess we've been
talking about them a little bit already
but um one thing that surprised us
and i just mentioned this is that um so
many of them were still trying to
understand what the problem was and so
it wasn't like they had a clear
understanding before we came and so we
in many cases it seems we'll be starting
with an investigation we're trying to
identify
you know kind of a root cause before we
try any kind of particu particular
solution
and so that's fine i mean but it is
important that we first understand
you know what it is sometimes it
involves recreating the problem just so
we know what it is we need to address
but after that i would say that you know
our solutions are generally two
different varieties you know kind of
chemistry solutions or um you know more
practical mic you can probably tell a
little bit more about
about that like yeah yeah going back to
our examples um
so for example that that the one the
case study that i presented in in the
presentation
we were dealing with a powder that was
um actually being prepared as to
describe the first principle
and
this powder not only contain um free
amino acids that we know that are hard
to dissolve
but also
some
components that could be easily oxidized
like the first form
of um you know first the first and
um so we were able to you know let me
modify that that formula so that we
could um get rid of those components
that were hard to dissolve in that way
and substitute some with the salts that
are
more easily
to hydrate and that way we were able to
combine all the powders into one
and also we solved the issue of
possible issue of instability with the
first form that could easily oxidize so
we will replace that with the fair form
of
of the compound
and
another way that we've been able to also
help out is by changing the method in a
very easy solution that exists out there
that um many people are still using and
we're very surprised they still are is
that they're they're doing that last qs
step you know where they
adjust their volume so they're starting
with
about 80 of the volume typically and
then adding the powder and then doing
that
volume
um adjustment and we think that actually
could add on our variability to the the
process so by eliminating that and
starting with a set volume
that actually
can control that variance
that we sometimes see
so yeah i mean many different ways of
tackling these issues of solubility
another
topic we encounter when we talk to our
users is
how
improvements that we develop in insect
could reduce the costs
for their for their cell culture process
could you speak to that please
well okay so we can certainly reduce
costs of their overall process but it's
typically by saving time
on the media preparation part um i guess
no now that you now that i think about
the question
so if we can reduce variation uh you
know in the cell culture process by
you know having a more reliable or more
consistent media prep
then i think that is definitely going to
save them money it's going to save them
a lot of headaches too so
as we develop
more reliable simplified methods for
media prep and even as we
design the packaging you know like ready
to use packaging or whatever it takes to
make that
process more
scalable more reliable i think that
saves a lot of money
and a lot of
headaches as i mentioned yeah yeah i
think you're right when you mention time
because
you know when you think about these
errors um
you know they do lead to costly
investigations we do do take a lot of
time to
resolve and also they could lead to
delays in your um manufacturing
scheduling so those are costly time
issues
but also you know once you have a
well understanding of your process and
your full control your efficiency um
improves in
some of those time
savings that you're getting from
um you know not having to allocate as
much labor and personnel into the um
particular unit operation that could
convert into actual savings as well so
there are many ways of thinking about
how to reduce costs
yeah and you know i was talking earlier
i mentioned human intervention so i
think that's a key concept that we're
trying to minimize human intervention
it's not that we have anything against
humans it's just that we know from
experience that the you know the errors
and the variation are coming from
when you put the burden on your
technician to make things work i think
you're just asking for issues so we can
avoid that by designing you know
the process so that it's not it doesn't
involve so much judgment and
intervention
and speaking of that information we've
had several situations where um our
clients had
difficulties getting their powder cell
culture media into solution could you
give us just a bit of insight into ways
for improving media solubility
well right so we i guess we mentioned a
few but for example substitution more
more friendly more soluble components
more stable components
we could also do things like
separation of components that don't get
along
with each other you know cause problems
because of interaction
we've even talked about what i might
call
complexation so complexing you know
metals with uh
with the key leaders or um
you know where they can associate with
something that will stabilize them or
perhaps maintain the proper valence
so those are just kind of a list of some
ideas i don't know mike you have other
you want to add to that yeah i mean
most of these ideas were understood
right
we are basically just taking that
understanding that it's
you know well known around the industry
and just applying it to our media we
know that certain components are more
soluble in the soft form
and that allows us to also
you know prevent or not use those um
ph saturations that are typically needed
to get those in solutions so we know how
to improve media
um so many components of ability but
also um
there's also like you mentioned um we
could
start looking at chelating um different
components and seeing whether or not
this could actually improve their
solubility
so
to summarize
based on these many discussions that
we've had with
folks in the biomanufacturing space
what what would you say to them what is
the real value that we can provide to
them for their for their processes with
the msat service
well i guess anytime we talk about um
you know what we're doing in terms of
cost savings or
or even reducing errors i mean you don't
really have to convince anybody that
that's valuable i think everybody's
looking for ways to reduce risk
to reduce costs and i guess we didn't
really elaborate on why
reducing cost is such a popular subject
these days i mean it's always important
but these days
as our industry matures
i think that subject of cost is becoming
more and more important and it has to do
with
things like biosimilars it has to do
with the global um
supply of
pharmaceuticals and and vaccines i mean
that's fresh in our minds we we're
looking for ways
to reduce costs and reduce risk and i
would say this program is squarely
focused on
you know uh very effective ways to do
both so i guess again i don't feel like
we need to
typically we don't really need to
persuade people about how important this
subject is um i think sometimes it gets
underestimated because you know it's not
rocket science so to speak it's really
focused on some very practical issues
yeah i agree with you that you know most
people don't really
think about this um you know in
operation we we generally think of media
preparation as something that is easy to
do and should be no problems and it's
not an issue until
there is an issue you know something
comes up in your process that starts um
giving you
you know um
scheduling issues or you know you're not
able to meet your supply of um these
valuable products to the to the patients
so we really want you to have a a really
well
deep understanding of that uh
interpretation so that you're you feel
like you're always in control and that
you're able to predict whether the
performance of that media will be always
reliable so you have um you could build
models with
um with the different factors that are
present in the preparation method so
that you
have that deeper understanding of
where all these factors are affecting
the performance as well as um we are now
utilizing some more in silico um
computational methods to be able to
predict
uh the stability of media
in this way we're able to
quickly understand
how these multiple components
are interacting in silico and then test
those hypotheses in in the bench so with
all these tools we were able to
really have
give you a
complete package where
you um have full confidence in this in
your preparation method so that is
always reliable and your facility
has
operates at its maximum efficiency and
even if you transfer from site to site
like i talked about global supply so
that's another thing that's important
like
you know making it more of an engineered
solution instead of depending so much on
your technicians i think that's always a
good idea yeah
thank you tom and mike for those
additional thoughts that you had um i
believe we had a bit of a glitch there
so
if you could just summarize for
everybody
here um listening in
based on the the discussions we've had
with all these
all of our clients in biomanufacturing
in bio production
in in all these spaces what do you think
the real value
is that the msat service brings to our
clients
yeah okay well as i mentioned borga i
mean this um service was not our idea so
really it was the the client's uh idea
they were asking for
help we found a way to meet that
effectively and in a way that addresses
the needs of many clients
and just again to repeat that the needs
are basically practical needs in terms
of
improving the reliability or reducing
the cost you know reducing the time
improving efficiency
so instead of being you know like um
a um well sometimes i call it rocket
science it's not like a highly technical
issue but it is actually quite important
and um again it's
something that addresses the late foods
needs um so
i think the value is fairly obvious
again the fact that the clients were
looking for help on these subjects
is what really validates um
you know the relevance of the service to
me and the fact that we've been
successful in a number of case studies
as we shared
so i i think that's uh
to me that's what demonstrates the value
and we've been quite happy to see how uh
how many people are interested and how
many people are having the same problem
sometimes i'm amazed because
it's almost like word
doesn't get around that you don't have
to follow these
you know kind of bench scale practices
when you scale up um there's there's a
difference between
bench scale practices and then
large-scale bioprocessing so
i'm sometimes surprised that people are
still doing kind of working
old-fashioned things
thank you tom a question that has come
in from our viewers what basic strategy
could i follow for improving cell
culture media preparation to ensure the
robustness of my process
well that's kind of a broad question but
i mean um
you know some of the concepts that we
described in the webinar probably would
help to answer this
i think
you know the idea of eliminating
adjustments i think that's a good place
to start
so that's what i when i talk about the
bench scale practices
it's common practice of bench scale to
you know do titrations or
qsing up to a volumetric
you know
mark on a volumetric piece of glassware
or something like that
but i have to laugh a little bit because
when you're when you're at large scale
when you're at large volumes you know
qsc and adjustments those are just
things that are not necessary
so you know that's where i would start
when i talk about a basic strategy i'm
not sure if that's what the question is
about but
you know that whole
you know subject i just brought up is
thinking more practically about the
technician
maybe it's looking at it from the point
of view of the technician instead of you
know the the bench scientists maybe it's
as simple as that i don't know mike what
do you think about that strategy yeah
definitely um
there are definitely different ways of
approaching these issues
and calling a basic strategy is a good
way because
yeah the i mean these are simple things
that we do to simplify the method right
what we're basically trying to do is
make it a more reliable
process that you can
every time be consistently
hitting those
targeted
set points
without having to do those adjustments
so yeah we definitely
have
very basic things that we
work on but once you go deeper into them
they're not so basic right um they
involve
knowing a lot about the chemistry that's
going on the interactions that are going
on and how to avoid certain interactions
that we know are going to be
you know
bad for the
consistency and the reliability of this
media so
we definitely know what those
different issues are and we have
identified them and identified simple
solutions
through the understanding of that basic
chemistry so
yeah i mean um it sounds
pretty basic to do these things but you
know that's why we're actually trying to
provide it to the
to the customer as a service because
we we feel that this um knowledge that
we've gained
that um every scientific has gained over
the last 50 years is something that is
really valuable for everyone out there
thank you mike um
another attendee is asking would my
formula have to be changed significantly
in order to improve solubility issues
during the preparation process because i
do want to keep my same formula
okay yeah we hear that a lot actually
just to clarify you know the final
formula of uh media you know is not
necessarily changed at all so actually
most of the projects we have we're
constrained by that requirement that
nothing changes the same
chemistry you know the same nutrient
concentrations the same ph value
everything's the same
at the end this is more about the
methods
of preparation
and so that's where we do like to
engineer the formula so that the
preparation can be um made more reliable
easier
uh more efficient
you know things like that so
basically don't worry about the change
to the formula
um other than the fact that you know
your methods will change now that alone
i realize presents some challenges
because
you know you might need to order
something as a new part number
and you know that's that can be a
challenge all by itself and you might
need to validate the new method but in
the end if you're interested in having
those benefits you know improved
efficiency
reduce cost improve reliability i think
those are some pretty valuable offerings
and so it's worth you know say changing
your methods changing the part numbers
of things
but um i would assure you that we can
achieve the same chemistry that's
usually what you know we're being asked
to do
right i think in terms of the chemistry
we try to always end up with the right
uh the same formula basically and um it
definitely um depends on the flexibility
of a client you know what space they're
in
how set they are into that formula and
if basically there's no way to change
absolutely nothing into the formula then
we start looking at um at the method
itself
and trying to see if there's ways to
simplify that method without changing
that formula because we know that
sometimes that's not possible so it all
depends on on our clients and how much
changes we can make to that formula but
we definitely like to focus more on the
preparation methods
and um simplifying that so that
like we said it's going to be consistent
and it's going to be um
you know with minimal
amount of risk
in terms of the errors that could be
made while preparing that
and then i think we have time for one
last question
does the msat service help with the
physical testing of new formulas or do
you provide just a formula on paper
okay yeah so that's that gives us a
chance to illustrate that we're really
not just you know
giving you a piece of paper or i guess
that's an old-fashioned term these days
you know just like a written i guess
instructions or formula
we really are also involved in you know
verifying results or
sometimes it's really just diagnosing
what the challenge is because
you know testing is definitely within
scope of what we do because we're trying
to understand and mike i think you had a
case study related to this where we were
actually looking at some of the
osmolality values ph values and other
factors
in the preparation process and how they
were impacting
the uh
the the preparation process yeah i mean
at the end we could have all kinds of
hypotheses and theories of what's going
on but you know we have to prepare those
um prototypes in order to test them
right we don't just tell you what we
think um on paper we actually
will um build those prototypes make the
media that you need to test on your site
so you'll have
you know either the powder or the liquid
media
we'll prepare for you skip it out and
you could do the testing on site and
then we'll help you with the analysis of
those results that's right so i recall
sorry interrupt but i think it was
they were wondering if the method of
preparation was impacting their cell
culture performance so we needed to send
the samples to them so they could
actually do the cell culture testing you
know we don't have the cells so they
were the best place to evaluate that and
that was a great
collaboration
right and we'll we'll build that doe for
them and build those different uh runs
or prototypes that are needed for that
uh run um this is basically the full
service um
yeah that we provide
that's great thank you so much both tom
and mike for giving us these overviews
this morning thanks to everyone who
joined us to hear all about the msat
service
i encourage you to visit our website at
fujifilm irvine scientific
and check out the msat service and you
know pose any questions you might have
there too
and uh thank you everyone have a great
day
thank you bye
you